so let's play a game of spot the
difference now if you were asked to spot
the difference between these two
pictures you'd probably laugh and say
that's too easy because it's obvious
that this picture of a lion on the left
is nowhere close to looking like the
picture of a green fern plant on the
right what's more a lion and a fern not
only look completely different they also
function differently
but what if i told you that if we zoomed
in really close and compared the lion
cells with the fern cells they'd
actually share many similarities an
animal cell and a plant cell have
several common features as well as a few
key differences
in this video we're going to spot the
similarities and the differences between
the two types of cells and talk about
their functions inside the cells so
first off let's take a look at some cell
models here on the left is an animal
cell and on the right is a plant cell
first let's try and identify the things
that both animal and plant cells share
in common
if you recall both animal and plant
cells have a cell membrane which acts
like a gate to control what enters and
leaves the cell
animal cells and plant cells also have
this jelly-like substance called the
cytosol which contains organelles or
small compartments with specific
functions inside the cell
animal and plant cells share several
common organelles two of which include
the nucleus
and the mitochondria
the nucleus within each cell type serves
as an information database to store the
cell's genes while the mitochondria act
as factories to break down sugars and
release energy that the cells can use
so now that we've identified some
features found in both kinds of cells
let's look closer to spot the
fundamental differences between animal
and plant cells
as you can see in this diagram plant
cells have an additional layer of
material that surrounds the cell
membrane this is called a cell wall
which makes the plant cell more
structured and stiff
think of a celery stalk compared to a
raw piece of chicken or fish the animal
muscle tissue is floppy while the celery
stalk is firm that's cell walls in
action
also plant cells have these special
organelles called chloroplasts which are
what give plants like the fern we saw
their green color chloroplasts are the
site of photosynthesis which is how
plants make their own food in the form
of sugars if the word sugar rings a bell
you're on the right track because i
mentioned earlier that mitochondria are
responsible for breaking down sugars
in plant cells chloroplasts and
mitochondria are like good buddies that
help each other and work together
chloroplasts make sugars through
photosynthesis
and mitochondria convert the sugars into
energy that ultimately the plant can use
both cell walls and chloroplasts are
found in plant cells but not animal
cells such as the ones in you and me
and luckily for you and me this means we
aren't green
in summary we just identified several
similarities and differences in our
comparison of animal and plant cells
while both cell types have a cell
membrane cytosol a nucleus and
mitochondria plant cells have a cell
wall that makes them stiff and rigid
think about celery stocks and they have
chloroplasts which makes sugars and give
plants their green color
all of these are just a handful of the
similarities and differences between
plant and animal cells
as you go forward in your biology
journey you'll probably learn about a
lot more but the differences that we've
covered are a big part of what makes
plant and animal cells so distinct and
unique from each other these differences
are why we don't see green lions that
photosynthesize using chloroplasts or
floppy raw veggies with cell membranes
but no cell walls now i hope that you
have a clear understanding of the
different cell parts in both animal and
plant cells and that spotting the
differences between the two will be easy
breezy